abdul waseel harbor me llamo abdul baset
salud 31 tengo 31 años estoy en brasil
desde hace 7 años llevamos este joven
sirio estudiaba administración de
empresas en alepo cuando tuvo que
alistarse en el ejército en 2010 tras
estallar la guerra pasó a trabajar como
motorista de un general del ejército
hasta que fue herido
me acuerdo que el 5 de mayo de 2013 de
madrugada hubo un ataque aunque caí
encima de mi cuarto el 4º cayó encima de
mí que por mi quiebre el hombro tuve
heridas en la pierna y en la mano pierna
mi amor
que lo que me salvó fueron las camas
unas literas de hierro
abdul decidió huir desidia y emprender
el duro camino del exilio como
tras un arriesgado viaje al líbano y
para no tener que pagar a las mafias
escogió establecerse en brasil que le
ofrecía un visado humanitario llegó en
febrero de 2014 pero los comienzos no
fueron fáciles a grandes cifras yo abría
porta agradezco que brasil me abriese
las puertas pero brasil cerró la ventana
cuando llegué aquí descubrí que tengo
que buscarme la vida es cubrir descubrí
que mi nombre no es refugiado gringo
abdul comenzó a ganarse la vida como
comerciante ahorrando cada real para
poder traer a su madre y a su hermana
tardó cuatro años pero poco después en
mayo de 2020 su madre murió de kobe con
tan sólo 55 años
hoy ya está muy integrado en san paulo
qué delicia es de mi tierra el sabor es
maravilloso
incluso trabaja como activista ayudando
a refugiados e inmigrantes es
vicepresidente de una ong llamada pacto
por el derecho de emigrar además de
apoyo legal y psicológico distribuyen
cestas básicas para paliar los efectos
de la pandemia recaudamos esta comida de
la cruz roja internacional y del
ayuntamiento cada también y lo
distribuimos a los migrantes
esta asociación atiende a más de 13.000
familias de áfrica oriente medio y
américa latina a través de la
solidaridad
abdú lo encontró un sentido para una
vida sufrida y marcada por las pérdidas